[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 78 société tout d'abord je
vous présente évidemment mes meilleurs
vœux pour cette année qui commence alors
en ce début justement d'année 2015 nous
allons nous intéresser à ce qu'il faut
espérer pour l'année à venir sur le plan
économique et social on va faire donc un
tour de table avec mes invités bon
bonsoir Bertrand Decré vous êtes le
président du MF des ivelines bonsoir
Éric prévau vous êtes le secrétaire
départemental de la CGT bonsoir
Jean-François Laborde vous êtes
président de l'Union départemental CFE
CGC ce sont les cadres et dominiqueier
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire général de
l'Union départemental Force Ouvrière
alors lors de ses vœux que je ne sais
pas si vous les avez entendu le
président de la République François
Hollanda a appelé à faire confiance à
cesser le dénigrement et selon un récent
sondage nous sommes l'un des peuples les
plus moroses au monde seulement 6 % des
franç frçais voit une amélioration de la
situation économique en 2015 est-ce que
vous autour de cette table rapidement
vous êtes morose aussi
oui Dom oui oui excusez-moi je prends la
parole en premier mais morose on va pas
dire qu'on est morose mais maintenant on
a aucune raison de se réjouir non plus
quand on voit toutes les annonces qui
sont faites par le gouvernement il y a
rien qui donne à sourire et quand on
voit les résultats notamment au niveau
du chômage ou des salaires qui restent
bloqué ou qui augmente que très peu on
est obligé de rester au minimum du
bitatif
moi je vais comme on est sur les
perspectives 2015 je veux dire deux mots
sur 2014 puis comme vous n interrogez
sur les vœux du président de la
République c'est que
2014 on a continué à avoir une politique
de de
rigueur un MDEF qui est souvent dans la
provocation et dans la surenchère au
niveau des des négociations qui existe
au niveau national voilà et puis un
espoir un sujet de contentement puisque
il y a eu au début décembre les
élections dans les trois fonctions
publiques une progression de la CGT dans
le département qui devient la la
première organisation syndicale voilà
donc c'est plutôt un sujet de de
contentement ah contentement en ce qui
concerne la CF CGC nous ne sommes pas
étonnés les cadres les cadres en
particulier les classes moyennes que
nous revendiquons de de représenter sont
aujourd'hui depuis depuis plus de 2 ans
les les plumés on arrête de plumer les
cadres et donc effectivement à partir de
ce moment-là quand on arrêtera de
supporter le maximum des des efforts
demandés à l'ensemble des Français bah
nous aurons peut-être un meilleur moral
un bon moral ou pas pour g de Cré pour
je serai mitigé parce que en tant
qu'entrepreneur je suis d'abord un
optimiste euh et on peut pas
entreprendre si on n'est pas optimiste
alors il est clair que les chiffres dont
parlait monsieur Ruffier l'accroissement
du chômage il est clair que les cadres
qui subissent une une pression fiscale
euh ça sont des éléments qui vont pas
dans le sens de de la gaeté et de la
joie euh maintenant maintenant je pense
que on peut avoir devant nous la crise
c'est pas une fatalité elle se combat
elle se combat par le développement des
entreprises parce que si les entreprises
se développent elles feront de la
croissance et elles généreront de
l'emploi donc moi je suis confiant dans
l'avenir alors aujourd'hui la situation
n'est pas bonne certes mais je suis
confiant et je pense que c'est ensemble
sur l'annonce de de l'augmentation de la
croissance en 2015 alors si vous voulez
je CIS la croissance c'est pas un truc
qu'on peut fait nos économist était si
brillant il ferait peut-être moins
d'erreur on les annonce on les fait et
malheureusement elles sont pas toujours
rendez-vous donc la croissance elle peut
se construire moi je crois qu'on peut la
construire on on a en France du talent
on a des gens de talent qui sont
capables de le faire et et c'est
ensemble d'ailleurs avec les PR sociaux
qu'on devra développer quelque chose et
faire quelque chose c'est pas la
discussion par le travail c'est quelque
chose que la CF CGC a entrepris avec
deux autres partenaires sociaux qui
malheureusement sont pas là ce soir la
CGPME et la CFDT depuis plusieurs mois
invit à participer depuis plusieurs mois
nous travaillons de façon très concrète
sur le bassin de l'emploi du Manois qui
est le plus touché dans les ivelines
pour mettre en place de la gestion
provisionnelle des emplois des carrières
territoriales ça s'adresse à des petites
entreprises des PME des TPE de façon à
avoir un flux de salariés entre deux
entreprises l'une est en difficulté
l'autre recherche des comp
et momentanément faire un prêt de
salariés nous sommes en train de
travailler là-dessus et 2015 et c'est le
souhait que que je formule pour les
ivelines et l'emploi en 2015 qu'on va
essayer de monter ça devra aboutir au
mois de février une expérimentation et
de cette expérimentation si on arrive à
drainer des entreprises dans le mentoi
on va essayer de préserver l'emploi tout
d'abord préserver l'emploi préserver les
petites entreprises parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont les plus grandes créatrices
d'emploi et potentiel de création
d'emploi dans en France et dans notre
département en particulier alors
l'emploi vous en parlez justement on va
je continue à rebondir dessus 10,4 %
c'est le taux de chômage en France
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors en
France dans les Ies évidemment j'ai une
divergence peut-être avec Monsieur Decré
avec le medf en tout cas en général et
certainement avec le gouvernement aussi
actuel peut-être même le précédent
d'ailleurs on nous dit il faut relancer
par l'offre ça n'a jamais fonctionné il
y a jamais eu de politique à ma
connaissance en tout cas de relance par
l'offre la relance par la demande ça
existe la demande publique la demande la
demande individuel et en France on nous
dit que la croissance tient parce que
les ménages consomment encore alors le
problème c'est combien de temps les
ménages vont pouvoir consommer encore
mais la demande par l'offre avec les
prix bas donc notamment les salaires bas
parce que ce qui fait les prix bas ce
n'est pas que la matière première c'est
aussi les salaires ça ne tient pas ça ne
s'est jamais vu ailleurs donc la la le
développement de l'entreprise ne se fait
d'ailleurs que par la vente parce que si
l'entreprise ne vend pas si elle n'a pas
de carnet de commande plein bah elle ne
se développe pas elle ne grandit pas
elle ne vend plus et même même périclite
tant qu'on aura ce problème de chômage
et de salaire qui vont d'ailleurs
ensemble hein on y arrivera pas voilà ce
que nous on on constate je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec avec toi en effet
quand on commence à taper à la bourse
avec des impôts des charge salariale de
plus en plus importante et on retrouve
ça au niveau des entreprises si elles
sont ponctionnées elles ne vont plus
investir donc si on investit plus on
consomme moins c'est ce qui se traduit
au niveau de des salariés n'ayant plus
de pouvoir d'achat on va réduire la
consommation qui est aujourd'hui porter
au niveau national c'est ce qui nous
portait notre économie l'économie
française 2015 comment le voir il y a un
certain nombre de facteurs qui sont
ouverts le coût du pétrole l'euro qui
est un niveau historiquement bas mais
aujourd'hui ce qui manque et je vaux pas
vous donner un cours d'économie
kénésienne ce qui manque c'est la
confiance et c'était le début de votre
propos et tant que cette confiance n'est
pas renouvelée on va rester frileux il
faut effectivement arriver à à créer et
ça je pense que sont tout à fait le rôle
des partenaires sociaux d'aller au-delà
des barrières et des préjugés que nous
pouvons avoir entre nous pour arriver à
construire des dynamiques sur des
bassins restreints de façon à ne pas en
faire un dogmatisme dans le concret
construire des éléments pour petit à
petit cré des dynami la confiance
important pour notamment résoudre cette
problématique du chage la confiance est
comme a dit Dominique rffier elle va
redémarrer si on a on arrête les
politique de rigueur qui bloque les les
niveaux des salaires et puis il y a une
question qu'on n pas encore abordé ce
soir c'est dans notre département les
question de politique industrielle voilà
on avait eu une rencontre inter
syndicale à l'initiative du du président
du conseil général il y a 2 ans je crois
que c'était en octobre 2012 voilà où le
président du conseil général nous avait
tous réunis on était tous d'accord sur
l'idée qu'on avait besoin de de
travailler ensemble sur l'avenir
industriel du de notre département et
actuellement dans la métallurgie nous
nous consultons nos nos syndicés CGT sur
les initiatives à prendre pour le le
développement industriel du du
département cette réunion qui a eu lieu
il y a 2 ans elle a abouti sur sur quoi
elle a elle a débouché sur des constats
sur des déclarations
malheureusement je le disais hors
plateau tout à l'heure le le Medef
n'était pas n'était pas présent bon
voilà c'est voilà bon vous étiez pas pas
j'ai Mme pas su on en parler au plateau
j'ai même pas jeai pas eu connaissance
c'est dommage effectivement voilà je
pense qu'il faudrait que on réfléchisse
et qu'on reprenne des initiatives pour
qu' ait une politique industrielle qui
engage à la fois l'état les
entreprises sur l'industrie c'est c'est
quand même le le le moteur de de
l'économie d'un d'un pays quoi si on
veut avoir des des services publics des
des post si on veut avoir des hôpitaux
de
créeration d'accordc vous dire
t alors je suis certes président du B je
suis d'abord un chef d'entreprise et un
patron de PME donc j'ai créé mon
entreprise j'ai créé tous mes emplois je
n'ai jamais licencié depuis que j'ai
créé mon entreprise j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir la croissance de la créer ma
croissance et dans un secteur Mor je
continue à créer et je développe
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je le dis j'ai
fait la proposition à ministre une fois
je vous m'écrasez de charg al moi j'ai
pas de rendre de compreministration je
suis pré dans toutes mes actions une PME
j'en suis le patron et je suis prêt
parce que ça tirera mon activité à
offrir plus de servic avoir plus de
salariés j'étais prêt je disoutei je
suis prê faire un truc je vous achète
des chômeurs contre des charges
enlevez-moi des charges et je vous
prends des gens vous n'aurez plus aller
payer je créerai de l'emploi ces gensl
ils auront un travail ils seront mieux
pay et ça je suis d'accord mais et je
préfère donner des salaires supérieurs à
mes ouvriers que de payer des charges
nous sommes écrasés de charge et vous
avez raison monsieur Russier la
croissance c'est pas avec la demande si
on a plus de salariés moins de chômeurs
plus de gens mieux payés ça consommera
plus je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
ne sont pas ce ne sont pas des charges
ce sont des cotisations sociales alors
elles sont écrasantes aujourd'hui pour
écrasantes charges ou ces cotisation
sociales le PCT de responsabilité doit y
répondre aujourd'hui il y a 7 branches
professionnell signer la qu' signé ce
PCT de responsabilité le gouvernement
souhaiterait 50 MDF dit oui et puis j'ai
une question toute simple pour vous ah
un SMIC à votre avis annuel c'est
combien ça coûte combien un SMIC annuel
ah je pourrais pas répondre est-ce qu'il
y en a un qui sait ça coûte un sic
annuel ils sont tous en train de faire
le calcul
1003 c'est de l'ORD de 30000 € on pas lo
est-ce que vous Croz que le salarié
touche 30000
€ non non mais que 300 € ça donne quand
même une bonne proportion des choses
alors est-ce que est-ce que ce PCT de
responsabilité ça répond en partie à
cette problématique de ça on est sur une
voie on est loin d'avoir abouti
aujourd'hui les entreprises parce que
vous savez la France est un pays de PME
moi on narrête pas de me parler du CAC
40 des grosses entreprises mais les C0
par définition c'est 40 entreprises par
définition la MDF c'est 90 %
d'entreprises de moins de 10 salariés 90
% la France c'est 97 % d'entreprises qui
ont moins de 50 alors sur le P de
responsabil ça répond en partie pas
complètement pas en partie nous sommes
sur une voie pas arrivé quand même
beaucoup d'argent qui est injecté dans
ce pacte de responsabilité dans ce Pact
de responsabilité il y il y a deux
choses il y a les négociation de
branches et aujourd'hui on retrouve un
déséquilibre entre ce qui est accordé au
au patronat au sens général du terme qui
représenté par les par les syndicats et
on a débattu tout à l'heure légèrement
hors
plateau donc représenté par les par les
syndicats de de patronat qui sont la
CGPME et M principalement et en
contrepartie les positions les accords
sont assez flous au profit de l'embauche
au profit des salaires bon là c'est un
premier volet deuxième volet qui est en
place depuis depuis à peu près un an
qu'on appelle le cice crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi quelque chose qui
est très bien qui au profit des des des
PME des TPE je trouve ça excellent ça
leur donne un apport de cash pour passer
la crise pour les TPE PME oui pour les
grandes entreprises et en particulier du
CAC 40 non parce qu'elles organisent une
au crédit d'impôt dont elles NT pas
besoin làdessus il faut vraiment mettre
l'argent là où on peut générer de
l'emploi et aujourd'hui c'est
principalement dans le tissu de TPE de
PME qu'en France et en particulier
Gén préfet nous a nous a réuni pour nous
présenter le PACT de responsabilité
après le cice nous avons critiqué au
sens où ce que nous critiquons c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de contrôle de
l'utilisation de cette public voilà
c'est c'est surtout ça c'est moi je suis
d'accord sur la le besoin dans certains
cas d'aider notamment les les les TPE
les PME ça c'est ça peut ça peut
s'entendre mais on a besoin à chaque
fois de de contrôler l'utilisation de
l'argent public si c'est pour augmenter
les profits des actionnaires des grandes
entreprises voire de certains services
public de banques il y a il y a quelque
chose qui qui qui va pas quoi
voilà vous avez pas adhéré en pacte de
responsabilité non on n'y a pas adhéré
et moi je je j'entends ce que vous dites
lorsque vous dites que vous êtes prêt à
payer plus vos salariés le problème
c'est que jeentends pas beaucoup de
patrons le dire ça c'est un vrai
problème bien souvent quand il y a un
dispositif qui est mis en place c'est
pas pour savoir je paierai moins de
cotisation parce que moi j'appelle ça
aussi des cotisations c'est pas pour
dire je perai moins de cotisation mais
je perai mieux mes salariés c'est pour
dire c'est pour dire comment je diminue
ma masse salariale dans sa globalité
c'est pour dire comment je vais faire en
sorte de récupérer cet argent des
cotisation pour finalement ne pas le
réinjecter et pour augmenter le bénéfice
des actionnaires et ça n on peut pas
l'entendre le travail dans les
entreprise se fait quand même par les
salariés c'est eux qui produisent
physiquement c'est eu les laiser au bout
du compte parce que le résultat final
n'est pas partagé de manière je dire
équitable pour pas dire égal je pourrais
dire égal pourquoi pas finalement mais
voilà
c'est je vais essayer de vous répondre
quand même vous employez des mots qui
n'ont pas cours dans 9 pour 97 non non
pour 97 % d'entreis français vous me
parle d'actionnaire je sais pas ce que
c'est comme actionnaire
moiou on est 97 % c'est quand même une
majorité écrasante d'entreprises qui
sont des entreprises dont le capital est
détenu aller par deux trois personnes ce
sont des entrepreneurs qui ont tous
territorial l'ensemble de mes adhérents
a quasiment été sont quasiment tous des
créateurs et des repreneurs ils ont
entre 30 et et 60 ans ils ont été des
employés ils ont créé leur entreprise et
chapeau bas à tous ces garçons et ces
femmes qui ont investis qui ont pris des
risques qui ont vendu leur maison et qui
ont des boîtes qui vont entre 3 4 allez
et 40 40 50 salariés donc là qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont dans la tête mais qu'est-ce
que moi je dis ce que j'ai dans la tête
en tant que patron c'est pas demain
quand j'ai eu le cise la première chose
que j'ai fait et j'ai eu du cise c'est
d'investir c'est d'EMP de créer un
nouvel emploi c'est laose que si je fais
ça je développe mon entreprise et
croyez-moi que la passion que j'ai c'est
de développer mon entreprise et quand je
la développe alors je je suis pas l'
altruiste mais quand je développe mon
entreprise je crée de l'emploi et je
crée de la richesse et c'est ce qui nous
anime alors après quand je vois tomber
l'année que je cette année on on me
hausse la TASCOM et qu'on me bouffe
intégralement le cice parce que c'est ce
qui arrive quand même ce qu'on m'a donné
en cice on me l'a repris on me le
reprend intégralement sur 2015 alors
vous y êtes pour rien mais mais c'est ce
que l'État a fait avec nous donc d'un
côté on donne quelque chose on investit
et on se dit tiens on va une surtaxe
derrière je dire tant pisit problème que
l'État n'entend par contre que les
actionnaires il suffit que un gros
patron et effectivement c'est du CAC 40
mais en fait ils ils emploient quand
même pas mal de monde disent je vais
quitter la France si je suis assommé par
les charges et on fait tout pour lui
donner satisfaction qui reste en France
alors que finalement des talents
effectivement il y en a certainement
dans les gens parmi les gens comme vous
qui pourrai peut-être émerger à ce
moment-là finalement on aurait le droit
de rêver à ça aussi c'est tout à fait
jouable filière si on prend la filière
automobile par exemple qui est la
première filière industrielle du
département
beaucoup de de PME ou TPE dépendent de
ces grandes entreprises vous avez raison
vous avez raison on peut prendre
de seeur le secteur de l'aéronautique et
cetera vous avez raison pour ce qui
concerneautomobile j'ai regardé les
chiffres je suis chez PSA Peug
citroëenne et j'ai vu avec plaisir que
tous les groupes français ont repris
entre guillemets du poil de la bête en
2014 que les salariés les les les les
consommateurs français ont acheté
beaucoup plus de voitures françaises en
2014 que lors des années précédentes et
ça il y a un mouvement qui va dans le
sens de 2015 qui va dans le sens du du
d'un retour à l'emploi français parce
que on parle des difficultés du chômage
on parle c'est positif on parle oui
c'est très positif et il faut il faut
que ça se développe achetons français
investissons en France hein comme vous
le faites et parce que quelque part ça
va être ça va préserver nos systèmes
sociaux aujourd'hui nos systèmes sociaux
que ça soit la famille que ça soit la
santé que ça soit le chômage sont
intégralement basés sur les charges ou
les taxes vous le dites qui sont
prélevés sur le salaire et ce n'est pas
un salarié de Roumanie pour faire
allusion à un groupe qui fabrique des
voitures là-bas ou un salarié chinois
qui vient fabriquer des jouets
auélectronique que le grand publque pour
la France qui va payer nos retraites qui
va payer notre sécurité sociale qui va
contribuer aux charges famille il faut
que nous consommions français c'est un
des souhaits maximum que très grand
souit je fa pour 201 plus loin et vous
avez raison j'irai même plus loin je
dirais achetons ce qui est produit en
France parce que je dis bien produit pas
forcément
français relancer l'industrie vous
parlez de tout ça et bien une entreprise
étrangère qui installe une usine en
France et qui produit en France elle
fait travail des salariés français donc
ça RA
cont Toyota
valencienne Toya prière
voiture qui est
produity pas un conructeur
franais euh on va avancer dans dans ce
débat je voudrais votre avis sur la loi
Macron al la loi Macron c'est une loi
qui a fait couler énormément d'encre on
a vu notamment les avocats les notaires
les huissiers de justice dans dans la
rue pour dénoncer cette loi une loi pour
la croissance et l'attractivité qui
voulait qui veut en tout cas
déverrouiller et lever les blocages de
l'économie française alors lors de ses
vœux le président Hollande a dit que
c'était pas non plus la loi du siècle
malgré tout elle existe cette loi vous
en pensez quoi c'est une loi for
tout vous retrouvez côte à côte des des
des décisions prises pour développer le
transport par autocard entre les villes
françaises quelque chose qui vise à à
remettre en cause certaines procédures
prudomales et vous avez le travail du
dimanche si vous me dites pas que c'est
unel prof dit pas que c'est une for tout
voilà mais euh attention je je vais être
encore plus sévère moi à partir du
moment où on fait une loi fourout je
vais dire que c'est qu'on a pas d'idée
politique on a pas de stratégie
économique et là c'est le cas on a pris
tout un tas de petites mesures qui sont
dans l'air depuis des années pour
certaines je pense effectivement au
travail dominical c'est un serpent de
mer et là on a mis tous les articles un
par un alors un coup sur ça un coup sur
ça un coup sur ça et il y a pas de
stratégie derrière c'est pas vrai il va
pas nous faire croire ce ministre de de
l'économie que derrière il a un plan
pour relancer l'économie avec toutes ces
mesurettes parce que pris un par un ce
ne sont que des mesurettes mais ces
mesurettes vont faire mal quand elles
seront appliquées moi ça me fait rire
quand on dit travailler le dimanche ça
va déverrouiller l'emploi quand quand le
salaire est bloqué on nachète pas plus
c'est pas parce que les
HE pour l'instant c'est 12 mais on sait
très bien que le but c'est d'ouvrir le
dimanche en général et lorsqu'on aura le
dimanche banalisé en plus il y aura plus
les primes ou les 25 50 70% 75 % dans
certaines entreprises
quiè la parole que B a salué la
loi c'est une loi de de régression
sociale é parlé du du travail du
dimanche mais ça vient d'être dit après
les les 12 on passera à 13 14 15 c'est
une régression sur le travail de nuit
c'est la remise en cause des conseils de
prudom voilà c'est quand même quelque
chose important qui a un lieu où c'est
là que peuvent être gérés les conflits
entre employeurs et salariés et avec des
gens qui connaissent les problème
puisque ils sont d'accord voilà alors de
Cré bah défendezla la loi Macron non non
défend pas tant que ça position non non
la position c'est pas de défendre Macron
et de dire qu'il y a une avancée il y a
une avancée il y a quelque chose mais
d'abord en plus il faud décrire
d'application il faudra préciser tous
les cadres donc moi alors à titre
personnel je Seris un peu d'accord
monsur c'est tout tout il y a beaucoup
de choses alors en
plus maintenant alors maintenant il y a
des mouvements quand sera-t-il
réellement des professions libérales
nous allons voir quand sera-t-il
réellement trava le dimanche nous allons
voir parce que c'est pas c'est pas la
loi ne permet PASC d'pplication
discussion bon on va voir en en tant que
patron je suis et pourtant alors je jeis
la grande distribution et je suis ouvert
le dimanche matin moi j'ai le droit de
le faire alors je vous un exemple tout
simple mais tout simple pour mon qu'il
faut s'adapter et j'ai aucune envie
d'ouvrir l'après-midi je vous c tout le
dimanche j'ai aucune envie de le faire
vraiment non mais moi j'ai pas envie moi
dimanche moi j'y suis dans entreprise
quand c'est ouvert donc j'y suis tout le
temps et j'ai envie de me reposer le
dimanche après-midi personnel j'ai envie
moi je vais vous le dire donc je me bat
non non mais je je B avec mes salar mais
je vais vous donné tiens une salariée de
chez moi qui est maire de famille
Cassière qui m'a demandé qui m'a demandé
de travailler le dimanche matin parce
que moi j'ai des étudiants ici à 5ant
une fon a la chance donc je peux des
étudiants pour le dimanche et et ne pas
faire travailler mes salariés elle dit
est-ce que je pourrais travailler le
dimanche parce que moi le mercredi si je
suis si je suis de repos j'ai pas Besin
de prendre de nounou et j'ai mes enfants
je peux les garder comme ça le dimanche
matin mon mari est là que d' bosser moi
9h à midi ça me va très bien elle me l'a
demandé comme
quoi augmenter son salaire en plus en
plus en l'occurrence elle est payé plus
le dimanche en plus dimanche le vendredi
je suis moins payé et le dimanche je
suis mieux payé alors en tant que patron
moi je suis pas forcément favor à payer
plus le dimanche pourquoi l'important
c'est que le salarié a une vie organisée
c'est en de repos et si elle veut
travailler comme ça pourquoi pas il faut
répondre à mon avis c'est justement la
discussion je suis contre les dogmes je
suis opposé aux choses qui sont
dogmatiques la même chose pour tout le
monde non je pense qu'il faut discuter
et trouver à chacun il yion à voir in
entreprise pourir qu'est-ce qu' vouit
bien des gens veulent il sont ils vont
me dire je suis très catholique le
dimanche est interdit c'est une question
de religion pourquoi pas je peux
l'accepter c'est pas par je dis ça
attention parce qu'on sait très bien que
le jour où c'est généralisé on perd les
avantages du travail du dimanche à
savoir le sursalaire et c'est ça qui g
oui pourquoi sur le dimanche l'important
c'est qu'il y a un salaire annuel si
vous voulez sur important pourquoi
dimanch sont plus payés que les a l'Ance
parce que justement céit Ferrié jusque
là et si on enlève ce j F granderdant de
l'augmentation du nombre de de dimanche
travailler et je suis d'accord avec toi
on risque de se trouver dans une une
spirale négative ce sont les femmes
parce qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des des
ce sont dans le milieu du commerce où on
va ouvrir le dimanche et la majorité des
salariés du commerce grande distribution
ou le commerce ce sont des femmes qui
vont se retrouver dans une situation à
être le dimanche complet sans voir leur
famille bien souvent on a affaire à des
femmes qui ont vraiment la nécessité de
travailler de travailler donc elles vont
être entre guillemets volontaires pour
travailler le dimanche pour avoir un
salaire un peu plus important et parce
qu'elles sont dans une situation
financière délicate bien souvent des des
des femmes élevant seul leurs enfants
donc socialement il faut faire concret
faut être concr moi je suisise de la
grande discribtion dans le commerce je
vous le dis droit dans les yeux je n'ai
aucune envie de le dimanche après-midi
le dimanche matin c'est une réalité
sociale on a bien compris c'est diche
ça quand il la semaine ils font le
diche matin il nous reste une minute
pour revenir très rapidement sur la loi
Macron la loi Macron il l'a pas inventé
en quelques semaines c'était au départ
je très rapide c'était au départ un
projet Montebourg et ça s'appelait
ex orienté sur le pouvoir d'achat le
projet de la loi Macron c'est sur la
compétitivité donc il y a un changement
de
cible on on a compris en tout cas que c
cette loi faisait pas l'unanimité autour
de cette table loin de là allez il nous
reste une petite minute j juste un petit
mot pour conclure qu'est-ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour 2015 éc prou en un
mot bah je rappelle que la la CGT fait
son congrès au mois mars on tient notre
congrès au mois de mars parce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter ce
qu'on peut souhaiter c'est le
développement du du nombre de syndiqués
je pense que c'est un souhait général
d'ailleurs pas que pour la CGT parce que
le le taux de syndicalisation en France
est très très faible et je pense que
c'est à souhaiter pour pour toutes les
organisations syndicalesier rapidement
écoutez moi je souhaite forcément la
même chose parce que c'est à travers le
syndicat de façon que le salari peut se
défendre ça c'est c'est c'est très clair
là où il y a pas de syndicat on va
couramment au prudom il y a beaucoup de
beaucoup de problèmes maintenant moi je
préféais avoir plus besoin de syndicat à
la limite pourquoi pas avec des salaires
qui permettent de vivre des saant ce qui
n'est pas le cas j' un mot un moton
Souha ce que souhaite la cfgc l'équité
pas l'égalité à travail Bertrand regret
responsabilité moins de charge la
croissance pour entreprises bah merci en
tout cas à vous d'être venu sur le
plateau du 78 sociétés pour démarrer
cette cette première saison enfantf
merci à vous quatre et bonne
[Musique]
soirée